welcome back well the month of august
was a bad one for joe biden with his
approval rating sinking to an all-time
low
as the white house tries to manage
multiple crises many of their own making
from afghanistan to the chaos at the
southern border on top of that the
latest jobs report shows
shows employment in august missed
expectations by almost half a million
outnumbered co-host and former white
house press secretary kaylee mcinnadey
is here to react kaylee good morning so
great to have you as always good morning
good morning have you seen anything like
this kind of a stunning collapse and
does it surprise you at all
look it doesn't surprise me because we
elected a president from a basement he
was not tested uh the only
challenge he had was that on that debate
stage where president trump absolutely
trounced him in that final debate uh but
so we elected someone without any real
scrutiny who had by the way a horrible
record in foreign policy we've all heard
the gates quote about him
being wrong on every major foreign
policy decision so all of a sudden a few
months and eight months in people
realize oh wait inflation's coming so he
has a 39 approval rating on the economy
oh wait kovid he wasn't prepared for
that either it was president trump that
gave us the vaccines all of a sudden his
poll numbers tanking there crime
immigration you name it and then the
afghanistan withdrawal which i think
just crystallized in everyone's mind how
incompetent how much of a buffoon this
president actually is
yeah what is it about afghanistan
because crime numbers have have been
there the border has we've had the
images they've been shown inflation
unemployment uh
not to mention a number of other issues
have all been there but afghanistan
seems to really left an imprint on
people and have sent his numbers south
what is it about that
i can tell you what it is pete you know
they're contrary to what the left says
they say we don't have any binding
principles as america as americans as
they try to wipe away the things that
unite us but one of those central
principles is caring for one another is
not leaving another american behind it's
central to who we are i don't have to
tell you pete it's central to the
military as you know well uh so i think
when i saw the polling and it was
extraordinarily high numbers of people
who said no i don't want to leave
americans behind and even a majority
saying i don't want to leave afghan
allies behind like the interpreter that
helped you and so many others that
principle when it came into question
when we lost a war we fought for 20
years left americans behind afghans
hanging from planes and 13 u.s service
members dead after 18 months of not
losing a service member i think and it
just really rubbed americans the wrong
way because it's against everything that
we stand together united for you're
right and the images are so stark
whether it's the checking of the watch
or the bowing of the head or as you
referred to clinging to planes and
falling from the air or even as you were
talking we showed the taliban flags now
flying from our equipment right before
our eyes it feels like america's
dignity honor
has been shaken to its core
yeah you just hit the nail on the head
there too pete it's compassion and i
think joe biden misled the country i'm
this big compassionate guy that's what
he did on the campaign trail he had some
teary-eyed moments and americans said i
want that compassionate guy but then we
find out when he's asked about the
afghans whose remains by the way were
found in the wheel of a plane he said
that happened four or five days ago
after afghans were killed he said no one
is being killed the checking of the
watch the gold star families who have
come forward it paints a picture of who
this man really is he's stubborn he's
not caring in fact i would argue he is
cruel as we've seen through the latest
afghanistan yeah well said when you see
that number 43 approval rating that's
incredibly low when you consider how
young ultimately his term is
if you were to look at
where they would look to recover that
number where does an administration like
this go to say all right here's right
now they're trying to go to the 3.5
trillion dollar bill uh green new deal
bill where do they turn to try to bring
that north
i think they'll try to turn to that bill
but the problem is even polling shows
americans are all of a sudden a little
rifled by spending they realize that
this exorbitant spending is tied to
inflation i don't think they have
anywhere to turn because an
administration like this needs to auto
correct needs to acknowledge wait
trump's border policies were working
wait the way he wanted to get out of
afghanistan was the right way wait his
economic policies were working as we
know black and latino people in this
country had more opportunity than ever
before their median income going up the
highest there's more opportunity for
more people but it takes an autocorrect
it takes saying wait that guy was doing
something right and i don't think our
stubborn president has the ability to do
that no you're right i mean they can't
autocorrect because they believe what
they're doing even if it's undermining
and crushing our country in the in the
process well kayla you're going to be on
the big saturday show am i right big
saturday and sunday show 5 p.m here on
the big channel
can't wait thanks so much for kaylee
thanks so much for being with us